hi I'm Greg I'm John now as some of you
may know I am Italian and Filipino
50-150 that's right and most of my
relatives from the Philippines are
actually out here in California so a few
times a year we all get together have a
lot of Filipino food usually there's a
pizza there as well and talking some
time and maybe throwing a little bit of
karaoke not rock bad not no no no legit
care you know you know like legit
karaoke John's white anyway I want to
show support for our Filipino people
because I feel like Filipinos deserve
more Fame cultural recognition so a good
thing my brother and mother the other
day were like you gotta get in really
you should like to consider what we know
viewing more filipino based content yeah
and I said maybe so here we are today
this saying yeah that maybe there's a
horror short film from the Phillip mrs.
Philippines horror short film hashtag no
filter
oh it's 5 minutes and 27 seconds long
this Filipino video got 500 14,000 views
it's pretty good no that's are you
yawning in the middle of this Filipino
video now that videos started yeah I got
to you on that I do have is loud I know
I'm sorry I regretted the moment it came
out rocks are unconscious my camera
supposed to be very calm beating up
myself about this Budong in a mall that
means the son of a [ __ ]
that's the first thing you do as a kid
learn how to swear and somebody else's
winner we help get down I love you he
nothing gonna go wrong today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like all these rack folks
yeah yeah I think a lot of the frame I
like the quick attitude I hope this is
the entire short notion well I like it
like if I didn't know this was my
[Music]
Filipino girls a Bella paint up to you
deliverance Makani
[Music]
nothing is just appearing the way out
she's applying
[Music]
I don't like that Oh what is happening
[Music]
[Music]
he's covering up the mirror
[Music]
[Music]
and that was really creepy I love this
make sure something at the end here
I love the editing of that yeah yeah
yeah ending of it was amazing I thought
like because there was a great frame so
there's like a lot of different kind of
angles and like they're quick yeah you
know yeah I feel like a lot of times
these horror short films tend to be like
a little bit more slower moving they try
that their shots linger on there was
something that was like kind of what's
the word I'm looking for
frantic vibe about it you know I have at
least some short films especially like
lower budget short films short films
that you know people are putting
together to sort of start out I always
get the sense that if sort of assembled
with whatever pace kind of matches
whatever yeah the stuff they shot is I'm
not really articulating this well but
this felt like they deliberately changed
the pace after a certain point you know
it didn't feel like it just kind of
moved and it was interesting because the
the switch from like happy yeah to
though like the terrifying stuff worked
really well like the audition was very
well done like that felt more than just
some cell of like this is gonna be oh
it's not gonna be happy yeah at some
point because when it goes back to the
happy music it's still kind of eerie
yeah yeah because it starts out in this
sort of bubbly place in and and it got
to a point where it it went along with
that for long enough that I was like I
guess I don't know where this is good
yeah like it plays out for long enough
that you stop looking at the room and
just start focusing on her and I think
that's actually good for what they're
doing here it is kind of a personal
little you know horror allegory about
you know just being your your own inner
beauty and outer beauty and and it's a
kind of a neat way to play that metaphor
cuz it's just the personification of
this lesson she learns they really do
like after a while that gets that extent
where she's got the X's and the googly
eyes
lipstick everywhere oh that was a creep
like the way that was all edited the
frantic pace of it all but like just a
little bit lipstick here then suddenly
it's you know like a little bit of
powder the whole thing yeah like it's
the perverted version of the painted
face and it's jarring this house and I
and I also just just for me I always
appreciate when people use sound for
well yeah like just really sound
yeah like when the TV clips on and
you've got that static and you're
cutting in and out of the static and
you're like it makes music creepier and
it makes the editing creepier it's just
having this droning sound always really
affects me I'm hoarse I'm always happy
when they don't have any dialogue
yeah well a visual storytelling man it's
always nice when somebody does that to
me when it's like oh yeah you told a
story without words perfect man this is
all it's real I mean every girl I know
goes through this yeah
every girl I know struggles with her
image and then it's very often where I
just see some random girl like I'm gonna
go over to her house and hang out with
her for a bit then you know she's got a
googly eyes yeah she's got her tits on
her head he's got a watermelon tucked
under her shirt well you know it's it's
poking it at just how far we'll go for
these accelerated versions of beauty
that's why we have editors to make us
more beautiful yeah totally to become
you know a fake googly eyed creature I
just think that filters are the key to
life I have a theory that it's better to
look better in a photo than in person
because when you show up they go you
look better in your photo it's the way
that's and then they think well I'm
gonna have that photo I can access that
wherever I am so that's best version
that's why it's so much better to look
better in your photos than in person and
you know photos just one moment it would
be weird of me to just expect you to
keep that one moment forever any classy
gentleman in business they will say that
to you any class you'd better to look
better it's how you look not how you
feel when did this come out March of
2015
holy man this is one of those shorts are
I'm like I would like to see what you
would do with more money you know like a
little more resource it's from this
channel
they have more Asian short films called
vid C okay so if you're Asian go check
it out if you're not Asian
get out way to get acquainted Donnie Yen
rogue one amazing is the Asian guy you
know we need every now and again we get
one of those were like especially now is
like Hollywood's becoming more
encompassing looks like everybody has
one actor where it's like Oh II just
nobody who's the black actor right now
and I'm always like there's more actors
than just that one guy I'm wondering if
that's gonna have what Donnie Yen our
they're just like we need an Asian guy
get Johnny and immediately gotta do is
get Steven Yeun and Donnie Yen in the
movie together I mean that would be cool
don't you know right here yeah they'll
be great see ya new face I can move on
that we have represents to fill the
penis sure all you Filipino brothers and
sisters out there would want just that
you need to develop some kind of knack
that rhymes somehow with Filipino so you
can get that catchy name like Italian
stallion but like Filipino Filipino
Johnny you're gonna be someday the
Filipino James Dean I know which actors
you idolize know I had the bullets if
you're Filipino and you to this channel
please subscribe yeah I do I'll be
checking the analytics we're gonna look
if you're not a Filipino and you're
still new to this channel hit the like
button 1 million subscribers I wish our
our show was in 3d to have Tyrone's 1
million subscriber count' brilliant idea
yeah you know cuz that's just even if
you don't like his channel just like to
be part of the journey to help get you
to 1 million subscribers yeah it becomes
a cause in and of itself yeah it's
brilliant brilliant marketing and 1
million is you know it's like a nice
number where you're like is the other
day you could get that big
watch one see it's a million he has no
more cool catchphrases John is reason to
GRE on Twitter on Instagram he's afraid
to put his real name on typing stuff I
can put it I just reason to John dan the
sound is good reasons to Jerry just has
a ring to it and you know it's keeping
the old stuff alive
you know I think our next short film
should be just a slow tracking and shot
of my face doing this sixty seconds long
and we get this like happy-go-lucky song
in here you could do that now make
liquor
which is what is this video